so originally
when michael was sort of trying to think
about what would happen in our season he
talked about
nya
you know miranda's professor being the
romantic relationship
you heard that right the whole miranda
and che love story on hbo max's sex and
the city revival series and just like
that i'm in love with you i love you too
i am so in love with you
and i want us to be together yeah that
wasn't the original plan i know it's so
shocking fans get a behind the scenes
look at the making of the first season
in a new documentary and miranda herself
cynthia nixon reveals that michael
patrick king the show's creator
initially wanted her character to end up
with her professor naya you're the
professor yeah you're naya wallace
why do you seem so surprised but the 55
year old actress says she wasn't really
feeling that naya was a straight
character and miranda's a straight
character and i was like that doesn't
sound very sexy at all do you know what
i mean to women who've gotten to this
age and are now just sort of fumbling
around that doesn't seem great in fact
cynthia says it was actually her idea to
have miranda fall for carrie's co-worker
che i was like why couldn't it be
you know why couldn't it be this butch
person that
you're talking about having for carrie i
am
your host
and queer non-binary mexican irish diva
representing everyone else outside these
two boring genders there's definitely a
lot to take in between these two and the
possibilities are endless we came back
to
to throw these characters into new
situations and let them you know follow
their hearts you didn't like us because
we were boring the first time you liked
us because we took chances and that's
what we're doing miranda and che's
storyline
definitely hasn't been boring you know
the title of the show is end just like
that and
it's open to interpretation but to me
that means
in a moment
your life can be transformed and the
reaction from fans well
it's been mixed especially since miranda
split from longtime favorite steve to
pursue dating che is this really
happening are you asking me for a
divorce
this is really happening even mario
cantone aka anthony told et he feels for
steve it's what they wrote and what what
uh what they wanted and i think it's
very uh
i think it's very interesting and
successful at the same time you know you
it's all that drama you feel so sad for
steve this ain't never coming off
i don't care what miranda does and we
all til that do his part as for sarah
ramirez the actor who plays che and also
identifies as non-binary in real life
they actually addressed criticism of
their character telling the hollywood
reporter quote i'm very aware of the
hate that exists online but i have to
protect my own mental health and my own
artistry this character is smart funny
witty
very human very messy and very confident
they really are not afraid to speak
their truth i also think it's really
wonderful that we have the first
non-binary
character series regular character in
the universe of sex in the city it's
been a real thrill and an honor to be
invited in it's been such a joy ride
[Music]
you